hi ladies and gentlemen
welcome i am going to give you some
instructions
and explain to you how the case will
proceed
ladies and gentlemen of the jury you
have been selected as the jury in this
case as you know this is a criminal case
and to assist you in better
understanding your functions and duties
i will tell you now how the case will
proceed
you are as i said in my earlier comments
during the initial phase you are the
sole judges of the facts
your determination
of the facts is to be based solely
upon the evidence submitted during the
course of the trial
when i use the term evidence
i mean the testimony of witnesses who
will testify
and any exhibits which may be marked
into evidence
and which will then be taken into the
jury room for your review at the end of
the case
please bear in mind some items are
marked during the course of the trial as
exhibits
but are either not formally moved into
evidence by counsel or not accepted into
the court as evidence so if an item is
marked as an exhibit
and not moved into evidence you will not
have access to that for instance there
may be police reports that commonly are
not admitted into evidence but they may
be used to refresh a witness's
recollection
while testifying that's permissible that
report has to be marked so the record
can reflect what report
the attorney may be referring to and
what was used to refresh the witnesses
recollection so that report will be
marked as an exhibit say
exhibit s number 12
or the number 10
but that
likely will not be moved or accepted
into evidence by the court that's only
an exhibit all right it's only items
that are accepted formally moved into
evidence and accepted by the court as
evidence that you will have in the jury
rule
the first order of business will be the
prosecutor's opening statement
in the opening statement the prosecutor
will present the state's contentions and
will outline what he expects to prove
following that the defendant
if he chooses will make an opening
statement through council
what is said in the opening statement is
not evidence
the evidence will come from the
witnesses who will testify and from
whatever documents
or tangible items are received in the
evidence
during the trial the attorneys may make
objections as evidence is offered
where they may address certain motions
to make they have a right and indeed a
duty to make objections and motions
when it seems to them to be proper to do
so
i have a duty to rule upon any
objections and motions based on the law
if you hear me say an objection is
overruled that means i am ruling against
the attorney making the objection
if i say an objection is sustained i am
ruling in favor of the attorney making
the objection
anything excluded by me is not evidence
and must not be considered by you
in your deliberations
sometimes these evidence questions or
legal questions will be heard in your
presence in open court
other times that sidebar or you may be
excused
and going to the jury room so that we
can discuss that in open court but i've
made clear to the attorneys
because of the anticipated length of
that trial
i will keep those at a minimum
the attorneys will be here early and
they'll stay late and if there are
motions or issues that come up during
the trial we'll try to handle them
before you're brought into the uh
courtroom or after you leave to keep the
inconvenience at a minimum
i do realize that being confined uh in
the jury room although it's much bigger
in a courtroom than our traditional jury
room
is not pleasant but i do if it does
happen i ask your patients and your
indulgence
you should not conclude
because i rule one way or the other on
objections or motions that i have any
feelings about the outcome of the case i
do not
but even if i did you would have to
disregard them since you are the sole
judges of the facts
during the trial from time to time there
will be recesses and during any of those
recesses i direct you please do not
discuss the case among yourselves and
when we recess overnight you must not
discuss the case or the testimony with
any family members
or any other persons will provide an
account of your jury service to others
including through any electronic needs
including social media
for example please do not talk
face-to-face or use any electronic
devices or any means computer cell phone
or similar device to communicate to
anyone
any information about this case
also please do not post any information
on social media about the case
the reason of course is that you should
not begin any deliberations
until the entire case has been concluded
that is you have heard all of the
witnesses
the final arguments of counsel as well
as my instructions as to the law
it would be improper for any outside
influences to intrude upon your thinking
if anyone should attempt to discuss the
case with you you should report the fact
to me or my staff immediately and i will
take any necessary corrective actions
if you have a cell phone or any device
that is capable of providing internet
access
and any device that may be used to
record or transmit sound or images
you must turn off that device while in
the courtroom
similarly you must turn off these
communication devices and cannot use
them for any purposes
while in the jury deliberation
please be mindful of these instructions
during jury selection you were asked and
responded to a series of questions from
the court
if at any time during this trial you
realize that you may have made a
misstatement or omission during your
responses or if circumstances arise that
could change or alter the answers you
gave
please do not discuss that with any
fellow jurors rather you should tell the
court officer or my staff who will
notify me at once
during the trial you are not to speak to
or associated with any of the attorneys
the witnesses or the defendant nor are
they permitted to speak or associate
with you
this separation should not be regarded
as rudeness but rather as a proper
precaution
to ensure fairness to both sides
if anyone
connected with this case or any other
person
approaches you or attempts to influence
you in any way please do not discuss
that fact with any of your fellow jurors
again simply tell the sheriff's officer
or a member of my staff they will notify
me immediately and i will take the
necessary corrective action
your deliberations in this case must be
based solely on the evidence
and exhibits admitted into evidence
without any outside influence or
opinions
of relatives or friends
additionally do not read any news
stories or articles in print or on the
internet or in any blog about this case
it will likely be media coverage of this
trial but you are instructed to
completely avoid reading
viewing or listening
to any newspaper or media accounts or
listening to anyone else discuss them
and you will notice that there are
cameras set up in the courtroom
so
that's why i say i know there will be
media coverage please do not pay
attention to any of the cameras
any media have been instructed
under the penalty of contempt of court
that they cannot at any time
record your images
or your names or any information about
you
during the jury selection process we
just had the cameras were turned off
they were not reporting any aspect of
jury selection
and they have signed
court orders indicating that they know
from the penalty that they cannot record
images or names of any of the jurors
additionally i must instruct you not to
read any newspaper articles or search
for or research any information related
to this case
including anything about the
participants in the trial such as the
parties the witnesses when they testify
the lawyers of course or the judge for
that matter or any court personnel
the strict prohibition against outside
research or communication applies not
only to printed reference materials but
also obviously to the internet or any
other electronic medium
you were not to seek any additional
information on the subject matter in
this case the laws in any way related to
this case or any other factual or legal
matter that may have a connection to
this case
additionally please do not visit or view
any place discuss during testimony
by way of internet maps or google earth
or other similar programs
and i'm sure you can understand why
this instruction is so important
information from sources outside of the
courtroom is not evidence
is often based upon second or third hand
information is hearsay
and is not always accurate and certainly
is not subject to examination by the
attorneys
a juror's improper use of outside
technology threatens the very fairness
of our system of justice and could
result in the court having to start the
trial anew
wasting the courts time and the party's
time as well as your valuable time
in the event such outside information
does come to your attention
again please do not discuss that fact
with any of your fellow jurors
it is important that you tell a member
of my staff or a sheriff's officer
they'll inform me and then i can
determine whether there's any corrective
action that needs to take place to
ensure the fairness of this trial
the court and the parties rely upon your
good faith and the fact that you have
been sworn to comply with the
instructions of the court so that both
sides may receive a fair trial
because this instruction is important it
is my duty to remind you
of it at the end of each day's
proceedings
since you are the sole judges of the
facts you must pay close attention
during the testimony
it is important that you carry with you
to the jury room not only a clear
recollection of what the testimony was
but also a recollection of the manner in
which it was given
it will be your duty to pay careful
attention to all of the testimony
if you are unable to hear any witness i
ask that you indicate to me
that to me immediately by raising your
hand
and i will instruct the witness to speak
loud or
louder or more clearly
as yours you will be required to pass
upon all of the questions of fact
including the credibility
or believability of the witnesses
your verdict must be based again solely
on the evidence introduced in the
courtroom jurors are not permitted to
take notes
experience has shown that note taking is
distracting
it is better to depend upon the combined
recollection
of all of the jurors and then upon notes
taken by one or more of them
at the conclusion of the testimony the
attorneys will speak to you again in
summation
at that time they will present to you
their final arguments based upon their
respective recollections of the evidence
again what the attorneys say to you in
summation is not evidence
it's their recollection of the evidence
and arguments regarding the
interpretation of the evidence
however it is always your recollection
as the jurors
that is controlling
following summations you will receive
your final instructions on the law from
me and you will then retire to the jury
room to consider your verdict
you are not the former express an
opinion on this case but or to keep an
open mind
until you have heard all of the
testimony and i've heard summations
and have had the benefit of my
instructions as to the applicable law
and have been instructed by the court
to begin your deliberations
it is your duty to weigh the evidence
calmly and without bias
passion
prejudice or sympathy and to decide the
issues only upon the merits
you as jurors should find your facts
from the evidence adduced during the
trial
evidence may be either direct or
circumstantial
direct evidence means evidence that
directly proves a fact without an
inference
and which in itself if true
conclusively establishes that fact
on the other hand
circumstantial evidence means evidence
that proves a fact
from which an inference of the existence
of another fact may be shown
or drawn an inference is a deduction of
fact that may logically and reasonably
be drawn from another fact or group of
facts established by the evidence
it is not necessary
that facts be proved by direct evidence
they may be proved by direct evidence or
circumstantial evidence or
a combination of direct and
circumstantial evidence
both direct and circumstantial evidence
are acceptable as means of proof
indeed in many cases circumstantial
evidence may be more certain
satisfying and persuasive than direct
evidence
in any event both circumstantial and
direct evidence should be scrutinized
and evaluated carefully
a conviction may be based on direct
evidence alone
circumstantial evidence alone or a
combination
of direct evidence and circumstantial
evidence
provided of course that it convinces you
of a defendant's guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt
conversely
if direct or circumstantial evidence
gives rise
to a reasonable doubt in your minds
as to the defendant's guilt then the
defendant must be found not guilty
a simple illustration may be helpful
we'll say that the problem is proving
that it snowed during the night
direct evidence of that fact would be
testimony
from a witness
indicating that the witness observed
snow falling during the night
so i i have young children well not that
young teenagers but they still like
getting off from school during the
winter time when it snows
and if there's snow in the forecast
invariably
my children before going to bed and
retiring look out the window
to see if it's snowing and if they see
snow falling at that time and they came
in and said dad it's snowing that would
be direct evidence direct testimony
that it was in fact snowing at night
now circumstantial evidence
his testimony indicating there was no
snow on the ground
before the witness went to sleep and
that when he or she arose in the morning
it was not snowing but the ground was
snow covered
so when that scenario i gave you if my
children looked out the window at night
and there was a forecast for snow but
there was no snow on the ground there
was no snow falling
and they were tired of bed but when they
woke up in the morning and they saw
snow blanketing the ground
they didn't see it snow but from the
fact that there's snow on the ground
they would draw a reasonable logical
inference that it had in fact snowed
during the night so they're drawing an
inference from a fact established snow
on the ground that it had snowed during
the night that would be an example of
circumstantial evidence
the former direct evidence
directly goes to prove the fact that
snow fell during the night while the
latter establishes facts for which the
inference that it snowed during the
night can be drawn
as the judges are the facts you ought to
determine the credibility of the
witnesses
and in determining whether a witness is
worthy of belief and therefore credible
you may take into consideration the
following
the appearance and demeanor of the
witness
the manner in which he or she may
testify
the witness's interest
in the outcome of the trial if any
his or her means of obtaining knowledge
of the facts
the witnesses power of discernment
meaning their judgment their
understanding
his or her ability to reason
observe
recollect and relate the possible bias
if any in favor of decide for whom the
witness testifies
at the extent to which if at all each
witness is either corroborated
or contradicted supported
or discredited by the other evidence
whether the witness testified with an
intent to deceive you
the reasonableness or unreasonableness
of the testimony the witness has given
whether the witness made any
inconsistent
or contradictory statements
and any and all other matters any
evidence would serve to support
or discredit his or her testimony
to you
during deliberations you may ask what is
more reasonable
the more probable
the more logical version
inconsistencies or discrepancies in the
testimony of a witness or between
the testimony of different witnesses may
or may not cause you to discredit such
testimony two or more persons witnessing
an incident may see
or hear it differently
an innocent misrecollection like failure
of recollection
is not an uncommon experience
in weighing the effect of a discrepancy
consider whether the discrepancy
pertains to a matter of importance
or or willful falsehood
as a general rule
witnesses can testify only as the facts
known by them
this rule ordinarily does not permit the
opinion of a witness to be received as
evidence
however
an exception to this rule exists in the
case of an expert witness who may give
his or her opinion
as to any matter in which he or she is
versed and which is material to the case
in legal terminology an expert witness
is a witness who has some special
knowledge
skill
experience or training
that is not possessed by the ordinary
juror and who thus may be able to
provide assistance to the jury in
understanding the evidence presented
and determine the facts in this case
in this case as you recall from the ward
dear questions there may be expert
witnesses called by either the state or
the defense
please bear in mind you are not bound by
such experts opinion
but you should consider each opinion and
give it the weight to you which
to uh which you deem it is entitled
whether that be great or slight or you
may reject it
in examining each opinion you may
consider the reasons for giving it if
any and you may also consider the
qualifications and credibility of the
expert
it is always within the special function
of the jury to determine whether the
facts
on which the answer or testimony of an
expert is based actually exists
the value or weight of the opinion
of the expert is dependent upon and is
no stronger than the facts on which it
is based
in other words the probate value of the
opinion will depend upon whether from
all of the evidence in the case
you find that those facts are true
you may in fact determine from the
evidence in this case that the facts
that form the basis of the opinion are
true
or not true or true in part only and in
light of such findings you should decide
what effect
such determination has
upon the weight to be given to the
opinion of the expert your acceptance or
rejection of the expert opinion will
depend therefore to some extent on your
findings as to the truth of the facts
relied upon
the ultimate determination of whether or
not the state has proven the defendant's
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt is to be
made only by the jury
the defendant michael barrasson stands
before you on an indictment
found by the grand jury
charging him with committing the crimes
of
attempted murder of lauren cataract
that's count one
count two charges the attempted murder
of robert goodwin
count three charges possession of a
weapon a handgun for an unlawful purpose
count four charges possession of a
weapon a handgun
for an unlawful purpose
the indictment is not evidence of the
defendant's guilt on the charges
an indictment is a step in the procedure
to bring the matter before the court and
jury for the jury's ultimate
determination
as to whether the defendant is guilty or
not guilty on the charges stated in it
the defendant has pleaded not guilty to
the charges
the defendant on trial is presumed to be
innocent
and unless each and every essential
element of the offense is charged or
approved beyond a reasonable doubt the
defendant
must be found not guilty on that charge
the burden of proving each element of
the charge is beyond a reasonable doubt
rest upon the state
and that burden never shifts to the
defendant
it is not the obligation or the duty of
the defendant in a criminal case to
prove his innocence or
offer any proof relating to his
innocence
the prosecution must prove its case by
more than a mere preponderance of the
evidence yet not necessarily to an
absolute certainty
the state has the burden of proving and
defending guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt
some of you may have served as jurors in
civil cases where you were told that it
is necessary to prove only that a fact
is more likely true than not true
in criminal cases the state's proof
must be more powerful than that
it must be beyond a reasonable doubt
a reasonable doubt is an honest
and reasonable uncertainty in your minds
about the guilt of the defendant
after you have given full and impartial
consideration to all of the evidence
a reasonable doubt may arise from the
evidence itself
or from a lack of evidence it is a doubt
that a reasonable person hearing the
same evidence would have
proof beyond a reasonable doubt is proof
for example
that leaves you firmly convinced of the
defendant's guilt
in this world we know very few things
with absolute certainty
in criminal cases a law does not require
proof that overcomes every possible
doubt
if based on your consideration of the
evidence you are firmly convinced of the
defendant
guilt of the crime charge you must find
him
guilty if on the other hand you are not
firmly convinced of the defendant's
guilt you must give the defendant the
benefit of the doubt and find him not
guilty
you will note that a jury of 16 has been
drawn in this case at the conclusion of
the evidence
and at the conclusion of the charge by
the court there will be a random
selection in which four jurors will act
as
alternate jurors
the 12 remaining jurors
will then deliberate and return a
verdict at this point we don't know who
the alternate jurors will be
whether or not their services will be
utilized
thus i direct that all jurors pay equal
attention to the evidence as it is
presented and to the court's rulings
which are applicable to the case
by ladies and gentlemen that completes
my initial instructions to the court
we're ready to
begin now with the opening statements
we'll hear
yes mrs compton i'm sorry judge um i
believe that the
state's detective needs to bring in some
evidence
you know what we're going to do it's
almost 11 o'clock we're going to take a
short recess and then we'll hear both
opening statements
and depending on where we stand we may
begin with the witness or we may break
for lunch but why don't we take just a
10 minute recess we'll get set up for
openings and then you'll hear from the
state first and then
the defense if they wish to give an
opening all right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you